set scene one take one what the hell do
I do with my life take 1 take 2 take 3
take 4
[Music]
Oh your eyeliner looks good
stop babe
[Music]
thank you so much for coming up old
thank you boys
bonsoir and Bonjour to you I feel like
we've met before you look so familiar
could oh hey delicious thank you yes you
didn't need any of yours that's ok I'll
lead enough for the both of us I just
want to oh it's good thank you literally
Jonas actually choked on hey there's a
road over here we can find it travel it
maybe find some people Oh
oh good me likee shiny shiny good shiny
is the best do you want shiny or you
want road
with you one you go a or be it multi
choice you can choose to you can do two
of those it's two choice do that you
like me like to both good option that we
do alien don't tell nobody that lead to
la nuke yeah every day no I just started
flooding the road do you want some ice
cream
[Music]
how you doing
no please don't call the cops
it's a drug front hey fella drugs and
ice cream
want some heroin on that cone stay here
give me 50 bucks it's fine wink Wonka
look under that cone what do you see
some good old PCP
it's me Mad Mike I run an ice cream shop
duh duh hey you can't bring your kids
here let's go come on what are we
waiting for
Yatta Yatta come on it's stupid [ __ ]
come on [ __ ] douche
piece of [ __ ] thinking hey good idea you
go that way I'll go this way maybe we'll
tell each other about the
[Music]